cécile duflot la secrétaire nationale
d'europe écologie les verts est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous cette campagne semble
confirmer que les écologistes n'aime pas
l'élection présidentielle et que
l'élection présidentielle n'aime pas les
écologistes je parle pas simplement des
sondages pour eva joly mais simplement
est bien de l'écologie qui tient une
maigre place dans cette campagne malgré
votre candidate dans un instant et
justement on imaginera une campagne
idéal s'il duflot ou vottem ne serait
pas passé à la trappe
on recevra ensuite christine pouget de
l' agence france-presse et puis perrine
tarneaud de public sénat d'abord
j'aimerais vous entendre sur raymond
aubrac la mort à 97 ans de cette légende
une des dernières légendes de la
résistance vous connaissiez bien sur son
parcours
oui ce qui est intéressant avec répondra
que c'est une légende toute sa vie c'est
à dire c'est pas seulement quelqu'un qui
a eu au moment de la résistance les
actes de bravoure de courage y compris
physique
c'est quelqu'un qui tout au long de sa
vie à cultiver cet esprit et a surtout
veillé à le transmettre c'est à dire
qu'il est laid beaucoup de liens avec
des enfants dans des écoles pour parler
de ce qu'était la résistance pour parler
des valeurs de la résistance pourquoi
ils se sont engagés de ce que ce qui
s'est fait au sein du conseil national
de la résistance et ça c'est quelque
chose de très important et je pense que
si on veut être fidèle à raymond aubrac
il faut conserver vivant de ses valeurs
pas simplement en faire un être idéales
mais conserver vivante son combat qui
l'a conservé jusqu'au bout il faut
parler du couple bien sûr et qu'il
constitue avec lucie aubrac et s en
double et réciproquement on se souvient
de l'acte héroïque de son épouse qui
l'avait libéré en attaquant un convoi
nazir à lyon c'était donc à lyon je me
souviens bien lors d'un transfert
c'est une notion importante aussi dans
sa vie a bien sûr esquissé combat en
partage et c'est plus qu'un combat
partagé c'est aussi l'épanouissement
d'un couple dans l'action dans une
période peut être aujourd'hui où on a
plus tendance parfois à se replier sur
soi ou même quand on est 2e ils ont vécu
leur vie à deux aussi dans
l'accomplissement d'un combat commun et
avec une joie de vivre aussi et
une gaieté une luminosité qui émanait de
leur vie et de leur engagement qui est
très encourageant toi alors il est resté
engagé jusqu'au bout et il ya encore
quelques jours au début du mois devant
dans le monde il signé une tribune avec
notamment stéphane hessel pour s'alarmer
de l'héritage menacé de de la résistance
justement des valeurs de la résistance
c'est un combat et qu'il convient de
poursuivre aujourd'hui
oui parce que ce qui est intéressant
dans ce que disait dans ce cas écrit
raymond aubrac c'est que la résistance
c'était pas seulement se libérer du joug
des nazis s'étaient aussi construire une
nouvelle société c'est ça l'histoire de
la résistance est aussi que dans ces
combats communs se sont forgés s'est
forgé un patrimoine commun issu du
conseil national de la résistance sur un
certain nombre de valeurs dont celles de
solidarité d'égalité de partage des
richesses d'ailleurs y compris du fait
de l'engagement des gaullistes qui
n'était pas dans une vision de la
compétition et d'une droite très
libérale sociale un état providence des
réponses et qui passe en mains assez aux
gens tellement c'est d'avoir au coeur de
ses valeurs la solidarité c'était une
valeur cardinale de la résistance la
solidarité entre les résistants et les
résistantes et c'est une valeur qu'ils
ont voulu conserver cette question de du
partage entre les habitants et les
citoyens qui composent une même société
c'est une valeur essentielle et il a eu
raison de dire que ces menaces et ces
menacés par la politique par des
orientations politiques parce qu'à
porter nicolas sarkozy qui est
d'ailleurs dit lui-même qu'il voulait
défaire ce qu'avait fait le cmr et puis
aussi par une forme d'individualisme
d'une société où on organise la
compétition entre les uns et les autres
et on a plus au coeur de ce patrimoine
commun une vraie volonté de solidarité
donc oui c'est c'est un combat très
actuel
ce combat là aujourd'hui pour raymond
aubrac qui s'inquiétait également du
troisième tour c'est après l'élection
présidentielle sachant qu'il a était
tout au long de sa vie engagée à gauche
évidemment on le rappelle françois
hollande veut un gouvernement où
figurent toutes les sensibilités des
ralliés du second tour il le répète dans
le parisien ce matin je ne forcerai
personnes mais s'ils le veulent je les
associerait donc voilà c'est tout vert
oui j'irai vous irez la question de
du gouvernement vous avez aussi ont fait
lire avec ce que dit raymond aubrac sur
le troisième tour c'est que l'élection
que je souhaite d'un président de gauche
et donc a priori de françois hollande
c'est quelque chose qui va susciter un
espoir immense
quelles que soient les engagements les
promesses ses discours de campagne et la
dureté de la situation et la crise qui
s'aggrave donc il faudra apporter ses
réponses et il faudra apporter des
réponses à la hauteur de cette espèce
parce que sinon il y aura une
désillusion une déception dans sept ans
pense donc la question tout le monde
doit à un moment ou un autre se pose la
question de remonter les manches mais la
question justement savoir pour quoi
faire et quoi faire ensemble c'est cette
question qui nous sera posée vous avez
l'avantagé d'avoir signé déjà un atout
je viens donc vous irez au gouvernement
la question c'est celle ci alors je vais
vous répondre simplement nous avons
signé un accord qui nous engage à
participer à une majorité parlementaire
et évidemment nous tiendrons parole sur
cette volonté participent à cette
majorité parlementaire sur la
participation gouvernementale c'est une
décision qui sera prise par les
écologistes
à l'issue du deuxième tour on espère que
les conditions seront créés pour que
l'état d'esprit de ce travail en commun
je vous avez rappelé françois hollande
appelle de ses voeux sera propice
justement à ce qu'on puisse engager les
propositions et les réformes dont nous
avons besoin
j'ai bon espoir simplement j'ai pas de
certitude à ce stade parce qu'il ya
aussi il ya eu aussi quelques
déclarations qui pouvait faire craindre
que se reproduisent le modèle qu'a
développé nicolas sarkozy de dire c'est
moi qui décide c'est qu'ils exécutent
qui exécute et ça s'appellera pas leur
peur quand françois hollande ou
d'ailleurs d'autres un autre qui disent
c'est le programme du candidat qui sera
élu qui savent manquera dans son
intégralité et point ligne simplement
voilé ccg rebours usa qu'il a dit mais
qui pensait d'abord à jean luc mélenchon
mais pour une raison simple c'est que
par ailleurs ce qu'on met en oeuvre dans
un gouvernement ça s'adapte aussi aux
réalités ça ça doit être sensible à la
discussion à la conviction à l'évolution
de la société
on attendra votre décision mais déjà eva
joly se re ministre de la justice a
exactement ça va quand même et c'est un
appel du pied le répète lycées vraiment
me demande
oui j'irai c'est malherbe en casting
alors la question justement dans votre
question il ya un sous-entendu je pense
pas qu'un gouvernement ça doit être un
casting
je pense que j'ai ce que fais tu de la
question c'est de savoir si on constitue
justement pour une place je vais
répondre à votre question à l'horizon
que pour moi et pour nous cette idée de
participer à un gouvernement ça
participe à une équipe où les uns et les
autres sont respectées pour ce qu'ils
sont pour leur parcours pour ce qu'ils
peuvent apporter pour leurs qualités
pour l'heure la connaissance d'un
certain nombre de dossiers c'est pas des
cases avec des candidats ça c'est un
premier point aujourd'hui après pelé est
le deuxième point c'est qu'eva joly a
dit parce que son parcours son histoire
que elle ne pourrait pas refuser si on
lui proposait d'être mise de la justice
elle l'a dit avec la sincérité qui la
caractérise j'en pense que la tâche
serait plus ce serait une bonne idée et
jean salençon la vie je voulais dit moi
je pense pas ça à titre personnel je
pense que la question c'est la question
d'abord d'une équipe et ensuite de
savoir pourquoi faire c'est pas
participer au gouvernement ou pas
participer au gouvernement
c'est que va faire ce gouvernement donc
elle dirai quelle direction il va
prendre quelle réforme il va vouloir
engager
quelle politique de solidarité pour
revenir à ça il va mettre en place parce
qu'il faut réparer les dégâts nicolas
sarkozy est aussi répondre à la crise et
aux racines de cette liga va jolie
montre votre candidate qui est en elle
sommeille toujours la magistrate s'est
pas un des problèmes de votre campagne
justement c'est qu'elle n'a pas l'image
d'une écologiste finalement elle c'est
une forme d'un vieux et d'abord le
parcours d'eva joly il parle pour elle
elle n'a pas été d'ailleurs que
magistrate c'est une partie thalys est
une partie très édifiante parce qu'elle
a été une magistrate qui a voulu ce que
les puissants puisse être traitée
judiciairement la même façon que ceux
qui ne l'étaient pas ce qui n'était pas
forcément on va dire une évidence sur
des affaires extrêmement compliqué donc
c'est son parcours c'est son engagement
non ça on ne peut pas lui retirer mais
c'est aussi ce qui donne du prix à son
engagement politique c'est quelqu'un qui
a fait le choix
après un parcours dans la société civile
d'engagement contre la corruption
avec le gouvernement norvégien par
exemple et avec d'autres de faire le
choix de l'engagement politique
bon et là c'est un chantier important la
lutte contre la corruption qui inspire
et donc une mission à relever pour
évaluer un gouvernement sans doute sans
donner de leçon à l'extérieur vous savez
on fait avec on fait campagne avec une
forme de tabou c'est à dire qu'on a un
président de la république candidat qui
fait l'objet quand même de suspicion
très lourdes sur lesquels ils
mériteraient de s'expliquer autrement qu
en les balayant d'un revers de la main
sur le financement de sa campagne
électorale soit le financement de ses
biens personnels vous savez que le
président avec lui tu dois faire
publication de son patrimoine
il ya des questions qui se posent à ces
questions il n'apporte aucune réponse
dans d'autres pays ce serait un scandale
considérable nous ça se noie dans une
forme de magma où on parle pas de ce
sujet et c'est très gênant ça c'est un
dossier que la gauche si elle est élue
devra ouvrir droit mais la question à la
fois de la transparence des questions du
chef de l'état actuel de toute façon il
ya des enquêtes qui suivent leur cours
et il faudra qu'elle aille jusqu'au bout
bien sûr parce que parce qu'on n'a pas
le droit de laisser croire aussi que
finalement y compris les autres
politiques s'accommoderait de ce type de
pratique cela acceptable et vos
ministres demain eh bien vous savez mais
je vous ai dit que c'était pas et je le
pense très sérieusement je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que ma conviction
sur la nécessité de faire vivre la
politique d'une manière un peu
collective sans renforcé de cette
campagne présidentielle voter eva joly
est ce vraiment voté pour la planète
nicolas hulot en dot
manifestement il n'aimait pas le seul
écoutez tout le monde peut avoir des
états d'âme et des doutes moi je sais
que jouer oui mais à d'abord on verra le
résultat de l'élection le soir du 22
avril et je répondrai la politique c'est
ça qui est bien c'est qu'à un moment les
gens votent et qu'on sait ce qu'il en
est c'est pas seulement des sondages des
suppositions des analyses
ce sont des faits objectifs le soin ou
pas des électeurs et moi je souhaite que
eva joly ce soit la surprise du 22 avril
c'est à dire que finalement
effectivement au moment de prendre les
bulletins qui seront devant eux les
électeurs se disent voilà le vote qui
envoie un message important sur la
nécessité de s'attaquer à cette crise
écologique qui n'est pas une crise
à part qui n'est pas une crise qui
disparaît parce qu'on n'en parle pas
mais tu es une crise très réel qui
engage les générations futures c'est un
vote qui est indispensable dans la
période
il semble que nicolas hulot soit
courtisé par jean luc mélenchon dont on
va parler encore un peu plus tard dans
cette émission un mois je rentre pas
dans les petites histoires courtes
henrique et des autres vous échapper
mais c'est pas une question d'échapper
ou pas échappé chacun fait ses choix
vous savez parmi les valeurs des
écologistes il ya l'autonomie et la
responsabilité
nicolas hulot comme d'autres est
autonome et responsable
voilà je les ai entendus dire qu'il
appellerait à voter pour la candidate
qui serait où le candidat qui serait
désignée à l'issue de cette primaire il
a changé d'avis c'est sa liberté et
c'est sa responsabilité
je suis écologiste est depuis très
longtemps je suis aussi une femme
politique parce que je sais qu'il faut
passer à l'action
on n'est plus dans un moment où on
essaye d'analyser les causes mais qu'on
doit décider d'engager la transition
énergétique de pas seulement dire aïe
aïe aïe le lit des 107 1 euro 60 1 euros
70 mais et donc on doit dire qu'est ce
qu'on fait concrètement pour avoir des
véhicules qui consomment beaucoup moins
d'énergie pourquoi ce sont les
compagnies automobiles américaines qui
travaillent sur ces questions pourquoi
on n'arrive pas à trouver des solutions
pour des transports en commun de
proximité du covoiturage pour permettre
aux gens qui n'ont pas les moyens
aujourd'hui d'aller travailler
normalement de pouvoir le faire par
exemple cessé réponse là qui
m'intéressent et je sais que pour
apporter ses réponses là il faut des
écologistes en action alors là vous nous
évoquer finalement cette campagne que
dont vous auriez rêvé quoi celles qui
auraient abordé les grands thèmes
écologiques vous venez de rappeler un
certain nombre cécile duflot et en la
matière eva joly reconnaît avoir raté sa
campagne n'a pas réussi à les imposer
attendait là je voulais vous proposait
de voir justement une politique fiction
une campagne idéal qui aurait été la
vôtre
un reportage saignée de bérangère dingue
là on aurait pu penser que fukushima
avait lancé un avertissement à la
planète que dans la lignée de 2007
l'écologie serait au coeur de la
campagne et le nucléaire l'objet d'un
référendum
mais en 2012 nicolas sarkozy préfère
demander aux français leur avis sur la
formation des chômeurs pourtant l'eau
réchauffement climatique progresse
inexorablement
on a aujourd'hui besoin de prendre des
mesures pour orienter notre pays dans
une véritable transition énergétique
au delà du nucléaire mais mais mais
vraiment sur un sujet global ce sujet là
est devenu absents on a parlé un peu de
nucléaire effectivement vous
au moment de fukushima maintenant on a
même une espèce de reculade du ps donc
on a des propositions extrêmement
timorés alors que ce serait le moment de
faire des propositions extrêmement
courageux les scientifiques évoquent la
sixième extinction de masse des espèces
au niveau mondial la taxe carbone ne
prend pas 2 millions de français
reçoivent une eau du robinet est
impropre à la consommation responsable
les pollutions agricoles
une circulaire vient justement de rendre
de nouveau possibles les épandages
aériens de pesticides en théorie
interdit il ya un engagement qui est là
qui est sur la table
réduire de 50 % l'usagé des pesticides
d'ici à 2018 qu'est ce qu'ils ont à dire
là dessus
comment on va y aller et comment on va
accompagner les agriculteurs ici il
s'agit pas de lancer la pierre à qui que
ce soit sauf peut-être au politique
quand il n'est pas leader pour faire
changer les choses
on a un peu le sentiment que en tout cas
dans cette campagne les candidats sont à
la remorque d'un certain nombre de
d'évolution des mentalités que nos
concitoyens ont déjà accompli et que eux
n'ont pas accompli il y à dison sommet
de johannesburg
jacques chirac déploré notre maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs
en 2012 ce sont les candidats qui
regardent ailleurs
c'est pourquoi certaines associations
comme colibri ont décidé de prendre les
choses en mains avec cette campagne tous
candidats
je suis candidate et je suis candidate
plus de 26000 personnes ont déjà
fabriqué leurs affiches et se sont
déclarées candidates voix l'agressé
alors effectivement l'écologie semble
assez absente cette campagne jeudi à
hollande a une idée explique que c'est
la crise et que ce sont les questions de
société qui occupe le devant de la scène
pourquoi à votre avis l'écologie
est-elle quand même un peu l'obligé de
cette campagne
je pense qu'il ya quand même une part
d'évitement des vrais sujets parce qu'il
n'ya pas que l'écologie il ya aussi
quelles solutions la porte à une crise
qui n'est pas qu'une crise financière
et quelle solution on apporte à un
modèle de développement qui à l'échelle
européenne est complètement essoufflé
ont fait la campagne sur des sujets
périphériques vraiment périphériques
donc je pense qu'il ya une volonté
exprimée ou pas d'ailleurs
implicite ou pas d'oublier ces sujets
qui sont des sujets lourds pour faire
campagne de manière un peu anecdotique
et c'est pas parce que l'on parle pas
d'écologie pendant cette campagne que le
dérèglement climatique ne progresse pas
que comme vous l'avez vu dans le
reportage la question de la pollution
des eaux et donc des conséquences sur la
santé est réel que la pollution
atmosphérique
on a vécu en ile-de-france et dans
certaines grandes métropoles de france
des pics durable de pollution aux
micro-particules qui ont pour
conséquence de provoquer des
accouchements prématurés d'augmenter les
maladies respiratoires chez les enfants
et même chez et chez les personnes âgées
donc c'est une réalité six mois
d'espérance de vie est belle c'est quand
même pas c'est un sujet qui me semble
plus important que d'autres et pourquoi
on ne parle pas de ces sujets là je sais
pas la faute des écologistes puisque
effectivement nous parlons on va dire
que de ces sujets là donc c'est pas que
nous faisons pas notre travail et vous
avez parlé d' eva joly moi j'ai entendu
eva joly sur toutes ces thématiques tout
au long de cette campagne
et effectivement elle était la seule
alors justement à propos de ces sujets
que vous qualifiez de périphériques et a
eu le permis de conduire qui est arrivé
sur la campagne de façon absolument
incroyable qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous qui est je le dire pour la lr je
veux dire le refais pas le refus mais au
moins la restriction du tout automobile
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces mesures
qui ont été annoncées à la fois par
hollande est à la fois par sarkozy il ya
le paradoxe si je vous dis que on parle
des sujets on parle pas des sujets
importants qu'on parle des sujets
périphériques je voulais vous réponds
sur sap répondent c'est pourquoi on fait
pas la dernière semaine de campagne son
contrôle technique pendant qu'on adresse
usa puis ça a des conséquences en
matière de lutte contre la pollution
franchement c'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux c'est même pas à la hauteur des
candidats c'est pas à la hauteur des
candidats ce sont des gens qui ont quand
même une capacité de réflexion d'analysé
de la société du monde qui mérite qu'ils
disent davantage de choses je ne sais
pas si c'est pas la question vous savez
les jeunes c'est pas des bourrins non
plus ils savent bien quand on les prend
qu on leur dit allez votre pour moi je
vais t'offrir le permis c'est pas ils
sont pas stupides je pense qu'ils sont
tout à fait capables entre 18 et 25 ans
de voir aussi des enjeux au delà de leur
besoin d'avoir d'obtenir le permis de
conduire est pour vous répondre en une
phrase le permis de conduire c'est pas
la possession d'une voiture et nous ce
que souhaitent les écologistes et qu'on
puisse se déplacer de manière aisée avec
une incidence sur le dérèglement
climatique qui soit le plus là
plus fait possible c'est à dire
favoriser les moyens de transports doux
les moyens de transports doux c'est le
vélo et on a vu que ça marche très bien
quand on simplifie l'accès aux moyens de
transport c'est aussi la marche à pied
et on peut faire en sorte que la marche
à pied notamment en ville soit plus
facile mais c'est aussi donner l'accès à
des de l'automobile en autopartage qui
soit beaucoup plus facile et beaucoup
moins coûteuse et c'est travailler sur
les transports en commun par ailleurs le
permis de conduire c'est aussi un outil
est un instrument d'émancipation ça veut
pas forcément dire pour posséder une
voiture il quand on est jeune drôle
c'est un peu compliqué effectivement si
on a travaillé à 8 km l'autopartage me
paraît pas être parce qu'on peut
travailler on doit pouvoir travailler
sur ce qu'on appelle les plans de
déplacements d'entreprise qui permettent
aux entreprises d'aider leurs salariés
ont organisé leur transport en
organisant leurs horaires en organisant
la possibilité partager une voiture
parce que ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
de voyage à quatre dans une voiture que
d'être seul ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est qu'on peut
travailler sur d'autres formes de
transport en commun on a l'image des
tramways ou des métros on peut très bien
faire du transport en commun à la
demande en zone rurale il ya des
départements qui l'ont expérimenté
notamment pour les personnes âgées
pouvoir aller faire leurs courses aller
chez le pharmacien pouvoir aller chez
chez un médecin et puis il ya ça pose
aussi la question des séries de l'accès
aux services publics en zone rurale et
de retravailler sur un aménagement du
territoire qui n'oblige pas tout le
monde à prendre sa voiture ne serait ce
que pour aller acheter le pain alors
ayez ria hollande en meeting à besançon
qui a fait qui a donné un peu son credo
et qui a dit je suis socialiste et je me
sens écologistes est ce que vous croyez
à ce credo du à le 6 juin tout le monde
se sente écologie la mort ça me fait
très plaisir ça nous fait très plaisir
et je dis maintenant c'est très bien
c'est une première étape
maintenant que c'est dit peut-être que
pour certains c'était plus compliqué
d'autres je trouve ça très sympathique
de le dire dans la vie de jean pierre
chevènement de la part de françois
hollande
je pense que ça lui a fait très plaisir
ldc sa vie enfin bon c'était pas très
loin voilà et donc et donc qu'on puisse
passer à l'acte maintenant parce que ce
qui est intéressant c'est pas simplement
d'en rester à l'étape des constats parce
que oui personne honnête m'enfin c'est
ce que j'ai souvent tendance à dire
c'est pas de manière on va dire
boutiquière mais quand on quand on lit
les études qui sont faites sur la
situation climatique sur les questions
de pollution sur les questions sur la
santé sur l'épidémie de cancer
on est obligé de partager le constat
parce qu'il est réel donc ensuite la
question c'est de savoir comment on
passe à l'acte et moi je suis
extrêmement favorable à ce que l'immense
majorité des politiques doutent qu'il
soit face ce passage à l'acte et les
écologistes qui le sont depuis toujours
qu'ils sont écologistes sont prêts à
user toute leur force de conviction et
aussi toute leur expérience et leur
talent pour passer à l'acte parce qu'il
faut pas attendre et on n'attendra pas
cinq ans et que les choses soient
claires nous ne voulons pas attendre
qu'il y ait un ou une présidente
écologiste pour pouvoir passer à
l'action engagée la transe la transition
énergétique ou lutter efficacement
contre le dérèglement climatique en
créant des emplois parce que la
transition écologique
ses créateurs d'emplois mais vous n'êtes
pas la pression quand même que ce credo
est un peu conjoncturel je dire parce
que c'est la première fois quand même se
sont écologistes 1 et ça tombe bien
avant l'élection bonne nouvelle c'est
plutôt mieux finalement si c'était dans
cinq ans ce serait dommage donc très
bien vous savez nous on est et on l'a
fait pendant la dernière mathias nature
avec nicolas sarkozy moi j'ai fait
partie de ceux qui ont eu ce qui était
un moment difficile mais de courage
d'aller voir nicolas sarkozy quand il a
décidé de mettre en place la taxe
carbone on a vu à quel point c'était un
rideau de fumée et que c'était une
opération de communication où il a dit
d'ailleurs de manière extrêmement
vulgaire l'environnement ça commence à
bien faire et voilà on se renie en lui
même d'ailleurs
mais nous nous sommes prêts à faire le
pari avec tous ceux qui le veulent que
ce soit des politiques mais aussi des
industriels des entreprises des citoyens
de passer à l'acte parce que il propose
de taxer les émissions de co2 1 pour
financer l'assurance maladie par exemple
c'est une option que y ait une vraie
réforme fiscale qui intègre une
fiscalité écologique depuis très
longtemps les écologistes y sont
favorables
parce que ce sera un double levier à la
fois ça permettra de dégager des marges
de manoeuvre financières mais aussi
d'être extrêmement incitatif pour aller
dans le bon sens et lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique qui est un sujet
majeur jeudi que la france commence à
être touchée directement notamment sur
l'île de sein par la question du
dérèglement climatique et de la montée
du niveau de la mer alors toujours vous
avez parlé chevènement et qui était hier
à besançon est un peu au off quelques
journalistes il a dit
bien évidemment un très petit score de
madame joly rendre l application de
l'accord esp élevé problématique qu'est
ce que vous ça vous inspire puisque je
suis là niant et allié de hollande et
comment vous pourriez l'être
rien rien la bonne nouvelle c'est que le
score de monsieur chevènement
n'impactera pas sur l'accord entre la
mairie et le parti socialiste
écoutez je crois que maintenant les
choses ont été dites par tous les
responsables socialistes qui compte
cet accord a été passé de manière délié
l'élection présidentielle et puis il
sera mise en oeuvre
il sera appliqué et c'est jaillir une
certaine forme d'honneur en politique
que tenir parole ça vaut pour les
écologistes ça vaut pour les socialistes
et moi je n'ai aucune inquiétude sur la
valeur de la parole donnée par les
dirigeants c'est un peu partagé quand
même au sein des socialistes parce que
certains en privé disque même je dire
j'en ai entendu certains socialistes
dire que même fessenheim fair sera ne
fermera pas la laisser comme la vie
répondra et on verra effectivement s'il
ya toujours dit effectivement que ça
serait respecté l'accord mais vous
pensez ça mais françois j'ai lu les
propos de françois hollande dans
paris-match dix ans la même chose et moi
j'ai pas envie de faire l'exégèse des
propos socialiste j'ai pas envie
d'ailleurs de douter ou pas de la
sincérité des uns des autres dans
l'accord il est prévu l'engagement de
fermeture de 24 réacteurs dont les dix
ans c'est à dire l'engagement du
candidat socialiste de passer de 75 à
50%
mais plus loin que c'est d'après moi une
fermeture de fessenheim ou bien vous
allez d'investir 20 millions d'euros
pour répondre aux exigences de sûreté
l'investissement est exactement la
question c'est de savoir est ce qu'il
vaut mieux utiliser 20 millions d'euros
pour essayer de satisfaire des exigences
de sûreté qui seront insatisfaits sable
étant donné le vieillissement de
fessenheim et sa situation sur une
faille sismique ou est-ce qu'il faut
attendre d'être comme au japon
parce qu'au japon ils ont expérimenté la
sortie du nucléaire en 18 mois casey
moins de 18 mois brutalement
je pense que c'est pas utile et moi je
souhaite que ce débat mûrissent et je
constate que et pour le coup c'est le
débat autour de cet accord aura été
utile il aura été utile aussi au sein du
parti socialiste parce que le débat sur
la transition énergétique commence et
moi j'ai bien lu l'interview de madame
lauvergeon qui parle par exemple de
stratégie industrielle
mais une vraie stratégie industrielle
pour la france aussi courageuse et
ambitieuse que celle qui a imposé le
tout nucléaire à la france c'est
qui nous permet d'engager une vraie
politique industrielle en faveur des
énergies renouvelables c'est ce que font
tous les pays qui ont un coup d'avancé
donc est-ce qu'on veut attendre que la
france soit le conservatoire des
vieilles centrales nucléaires pendant
que l'ensemble du monde a changé à la
fois de doctrine énergétique de
stratégie est aussi d'entreprises être
obligés d'importer le cerveau en terre
si tu centrales de troisième génération
imagine la quatrième génération ont
abandonné leurs recherches
ça fait 30 ans qu'on imagine la
quatrième génération quand on a lancé
programme électronucléaire français vous
savez ce qu'on a dit en 1973 quand on
démantèlera la première centrale
on saura traiter le problème des déchets
nucléaires on ne sait pas le traité et
on sait qu'on ne saura sans doute jamais
le traité voilà la réalité donc les
écologistes sont très pragmatiques et 10
il faut maintenant inverser la tendance
réorienter nos investissements
industriels avoir une vraie politique
industrielle
pas seulement au niveau français mais au
niveau européen comme on a créé l'union
européenne son histoire vient la
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier
on veut très bien se dire que avec ses
capacités d'ingénierie ses capacités
industrielles
l'europe peut être le territoire d'une
vraie communauté européenne des énergies
renouvelables et ça c'est un projet
d'avenir qui plus est créateur d'emploi
parce que à ceux qui ont peur des
dépenses de notre pays et qui en plus
savent que le chômage est un mal
endémique
on ne peut pas ne pas constater qu'en
allemagne il y a eu beaucoup de création
d'emplois etc au kilowattheure produit
il ya trois fois plus d'emplois dans les
énergies renouvelables que dans le
nucléaire
mais alors si françois hollande est élu
et s'ils respectent l'accord je veux
dire combien de temps vous lui donnez
pour fermer fessenheim
non mais on va essayer on n'est pas dans
cette logique là en aura on nous on est
prêt à avoir le débat et je vous dis
c'est pas que fessenheim
on va être très tranquille la question
de la politique énergétique se résoudra
pas à un symbole c'est très urgent parce
qu'on sait très bien que le risque
majeur il est sûre cette centrale
et tout le monde le sait y compris des
syndicalistes qui ont dit on peut fermer
fessenheim sans dégâts sociaux parce que
la vérité est là et c'est absolument
irresponsable de la part du président de
la république actuel nicolas sarkozy
d'aller s'échauffer les salariés en
disant on veut vous mettre dehors c'est
vraiment mais le degré moins 12 de la
politique voilà alors justement un
nicolas sarkozy françois fillon met en
garde contre une victoire de françois
hollande
il estime que cela relancerait les
attaques spéculatives contre notre pays
et contre leur aura tous pernaut sto et
puis on va avoir des points face à
l'inter des oreilles et françois fillon
confirme dans une interview à paraître
dans le figaro magazine il dit que si
hollande gagne il y aura des turbulences
redoutable pour notre pays et que la
france serait à genoux que répondez-vous
et que pensez vous de ces je vous assure
enfin normalement
je m'estime à une certaine intelligence
de françois fillon
là on atteint des niveaux qui confine à
l'arrivée des chars russes sur la place
de la nation
si limitée françois mitterrand est élu
enfin je veux bien qu'on vive cette
campagne avec 30 ans de retard mais là y
compris les dirigeants de droite font la
même chose je vous disais les poils dans
les oreilles enfin les arguments
deviennent complètement fantasque où ils
ont perdu les pédales
ou alors ils sont eux mêmes pas dupes du
n'importe quoi qui sont en train de dire
dans les deux cas c'est pas très
glorieux et et mélenchon lors je veux
dire qui semble avoir un peu préempter
je veux dire les thèmes écolos qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous en pensez
pourquoi vous êtes fait capter un peu
tous les sujets de près de vous vos
sujets de prédilection mais vous savez
je crois d'abord que il faut pas
résoudre
pardon résumer la vie politique
française à l'élection présidentielle il
ya eu des millions de gens qui ont voté
pour les listes des écologistes aux
élections régionales et avant aux
élections européennes et même à une
élection qui a priori ne nous est pas
favorable aux élections cantonales d'il
ya exactement un an
nous sommes les seuls partis politiques
a progressé en nombre de voix entre deux
élections donc cette tendance de fond
elle continuera d'exister et elle
existera après la présidentielle on a un
moment conjoncturel particulier d'une
élection extrêmement spéciale
extrêmement française et qui ont plus a
atteint un niveau de caricature
d'elle-même
lors de cette élection présidentielle
qui s'explique aussi par l'ultra
personnalisation de l'exercice du mandat
de président avec quel candidat sarkozy
et peut donc jean luc mélenchon et
rentrer complètement dans ce jeu où le
surnommer en privé le che guevara j'ai
plein
et vous savez je dis beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de moments j'ai compris sur moi
même donc faut que tous lâché quand même
sur jean luc mélenchon quand même le
gosplan nom vient de choses qui ont été
dit sur ce que signifie aujourd'hui la
discordance entre le discours et les
actes
il se trouve qu'il ya beaucoup
d'écologistes élus dans les conseils
régionaux élus dans les conseils
municipaux avec des camarades du front
de gauche et qui constate que sur des
luttes écologistes sur des politiques
écologistes qu'on voudrait mettre en
place on manque de leurs soutiens qu'on
souhaiterait alors j'espère qu'après
cette campagne la conversion sera
complète au sein du front de gauche et
qu'on pourra compter sur les élus y
compris les élus communistes pour
engager ce changement parce que le grand
discours sur l'écologie de jean-luc
mélenchon à clermont ferrand
c'est dans la belle vie ou un combat
essentiel a été mené est toujours mené
pour l'instant est en difficulté c'est
celui contre un incinérateur géant qui
est un gâchis environnemental et sans
doute préjudiciable en termes de
s'envoler au premier port et sa
conversion non je n'ai pas dit ça je dis
jugeront sur pièce et pour l'instant je
dis que ce sont des voix du front de
gauche qui ont permis d'adopter la
construction cet incinérateur
j'espère qu'après ce grand moment de
2012 les choses vont changer
6 heures d'accord merci les fêtes je
prolonge une question de cuisine sur le
permis de conduire et sur l'essence est
ce que vous n'aurez une question simple
françois hollande promet pour un temps
en tous les cas le blocage des prix de
l'essence vous êtes d'accord oui ou non
vous avez la mission en cette mesure
chez vous bien c'est exactement le débat
qu'on va voir on parlait tout est ce que
oui ou non on s'attaque à un sujet
majeur que les écologistes ou annonce
depuis longtemps qui est le
renchérissement considérable du prix de
l'énergie et du pétrole
blu quel prix les sens si c'est pour
quand on le débloquera que ce soit 2 ou
3 euros le litre ça ne sert à rien ce
qu'il faut c'est faire en sorte qu'on
ait des voitures moins consommatrices
d'énergie que l'on puisse changer les
mots du portefeuille mobile
vous savez moi je pense qu'on s'adresse
à des citoyens intelligents et soulager
quelques temps pour que ce soit pire
après ça n'est qu'une solution
temporaire
donc il faut donner les moyens aux gens
et c'est ça que permet la contribution
climat énergie est une vraie fiscalité
écologique de changer leur mode de
chauffage parce que moi je pense à
toutes ces personnes âgées qui cet hiver
la pompe à ce que c'est le même sujet
ils n'ont pas eu les moyens de remplir
leurs cuves de fioul et de se chauffer
la précarité énergétique c'est 13% de la
population française oui qui est des
gens qui ont du mal à remplir et à faire
le plein c'est une réalité mais si on
leur dit pendant deux mois là pour que
ça passe on va vous faire un petit
chèque sauf que ensuite c'est reparti en
pire ça ne servira à rien c'est ça qui
est dramatique
donc il peut y avoir des mesures
sociales temporaire il doit y avoir des
mesures durables qui permettent
d'engager la transition énergétique
d'accord c'est clair on a compris ça ne
servirait à rien c'est une proposition
de france et nice il ya que ça le
blocage n'a pas des mesures de fond qui
ferment urgence nous on n'a pas des
mesures de fond qui permettent d'engager
la transition énergétique alors des
mesures conjoncturelles qui peuvent être
nécessaires ne servent à rien voilà cent
jours mais si vous voulez faire cécile
duflot à ma place portrait non non non
non non non tant qu un combat difficile
s'annonce pour vous à paris vous avez
dit votre confiance dans un instant avec
les teens dans l'application de l'accord
entre les socialistes et europe ecologie
les verts mais pourtant à paris c'est ce
qu'on voit avec jérôme rivière on vous
attend de pied ferme pour vous bouter
hors de la capitale
on lui prédit l'enfer ou au moins un
parcours du combattant
en franchissant le périphérique cécile
duflot c'est que l'accueil socialiste ne
sera pas des plus chaleureux dans une
circonscription pourtant acquise à la
gauche car sur ses terres une députée
socialiste implantée depuis longtemps et
élus à près de 70% ne compte pas rendre
les armes
elle se fiche excusez moi l'expression
de la tête de ses électrices et de ses
électeurs
quand on est une première secrétaire
d'un parti politique
on va battre la droite on ne va pas se
battre contre une femme sortante
parce que nous n'aurons à ce rythme là
jamais la parité en politique
parachutage parité manque de courage
tous les noms d'oiseaux sont utilisés
pour qualifier son transfert du val de
marne où elle est née à la capitale tant
convoité sur le terrain si les militants
sont pour l'instant entièrement tourné
vers la présidentielle
on ne voit pas quelle cohérence cette
candidature peut représenter
on ne racontera pas que c'est en un mois
le campagne que l'on s'implante sur un
terrain clairement vous voyez pas aller
faire campagne pour ces situations c'est
clair chose qui est claire c'est celle
là c'est au fond c'est presque blessé de
ne pas avoir été consultés pas un
socialiste pour se réjouir de l'arrivée
d'une telle personnalité
pas même ceux qui dans les instances
doivent défendre l'accord signé je pense
que le parachutage de cécile duflot est
une erreur être parachuté dans une
circonscription bétonner à gauche où il
ya une femme sortante et à peut-être
avec d'autres ambitions sur paris mais
les législatives à paris ne sont pas un
marchepied pour d'autres élections la
crainte des socialistes c'est l'élection
municipale de 2014 ou bertrand delanoë
voix ans anne hidalgo sanofi légitime
au ps certains disques offrir cette
circonscription à cécile duflot c'est
faire entrer le loup dans la bergerie
un lot qui pourrait de plus en plus rôdé
autour de la mairie lahlou dites-moi les
couteaux sont sortis visiblement à paris
avec ce parachutage circonscription
bétonné davance comme ils disent dans ce
reportage qu'on vient de voir vous
n'avez pas peur des gratiné votre votre
image vous savez moi je suis une femme
politique qui à la constance de ses
convictions et qui assume un certain
nombre de positions
donc je sais aussi que il peut y avoir
parfois comment on disait d'ailleurs
nathalie kosciusko morizet et un
concours de lâcheté et d'inélégance de
certains beaucoup savent les ressorts et
les soubassements de cette histoire moi
ce que j'assume c'est d'être candidate
aux législatives est d'avoir choisi
effectivement après 17 ans de ma vie
passée à montereau-fault-yonne 19 ans à
villeneuve saint georges de désormais
vivre ma vie et ma vie politique à paris
voilà c'est comme ça on vous reproche de
prendre la place d'une femme qui est
mort depuis longtemps
mon ambition vous avez moi je sais je
sais comment on fait un accord est un
accord sur des circonscriptions en
l'absence de la proportionnelle ce que
demandent les écologistes et ce que
j'espère nous mettrons en oeuvre dans la
prochaine mandature puisque ça fait
partie de cet accord c'est la
possibilité de pouvoir faire élire les
députés qu'on souhaite des couleurs
politiques qu'on souhaite le mode de
scrutin français qui est une exception
dans les 27 pays de l'ue
sauf qu en angleterre même pas en écosse
il enfin le gaz scrutin là il y aura pas
de proportionnelle exactement donc il
faut réparer cette absence de
proportionnelle est aussi et c'est le
sens de l'accord être capable d'assumer
de pouvoir faire un contrat de mandature
et les deux sont liés les deux sont liés
et on a fait ce choix et d'assumer
d'être dans une situation où pour que
les écologistes puisse être plus que 3
la centrafrique et la place d'une femme
mais pas d'un homme non mais c'est pas
piquer un jeu
je n'accepte pas vraiment le terme de
parachute ou blindés habitués donc on
peut y aller et ni piqué seul le choix
des socialistes et le choix des
socialistes
par ailleurs personne n'est titulaire à
vie ni moi ni d'autres d'ailleurs d'un
certain de circonscrire déjà et pour sa
voix pour pour faire élire autant
d'hommes que de femmes
on peut très bien le faire c'est une
question de volonté on a élu 10
sénateurs 55 femmes lors des dernières
élections sénatoriales j'espère que ce
sera le cas et je suis vraiment sûr que
ce sera le cas pour les écologistes à
l'élection il est déjà sur le cas sur
françois fillon a commencé sa campagne
dans cette très doucement très doucement
bah oui on en a parlé dans quels cas 15
qu'on sait très bien qu'au viol
complètement et je fais je rencontre
concrètement beaucoup de gens sans
caméra très discrètement parce que parce
que je peux entendre les critiques sur
le fait qu'effectivement je ne suis pas
allé à paris xième arrondissement
ça c'est vrai et par ailleurs je ne
pense pas non plus que la vie politique
de qui que ce soit se résume à un droit
de naissance sur un territoire qui par
ailleurs est modifiable puisque la
circonscription actuelle pas du tout la
circonscription qui faisait l'objet de
l'élection il ya cinq ans voilà je gagne
la réalité voilà la réalité c'est celle
là c'est un peu compliqué mais moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est ce qui m'importe
c'est que on soit capable de faire vivre
une dynamique de rassemblement est aussi
de montrer que la complémentarité que
l'apport des écologistes est
indispensable et utile à l'ensemble de
la gauche bertrand delanoë y seraient
pour des primaires à gauche pour les
municipales de 2014 à paris c'est une
bonne idée ça franchement je pense que
la question qui se pose pour l'instant
c'est de gagner l'élection
présidentielle et se poser la question
des municipal sans connaître et quand on
sait en plus ce qu'on a vécu avec on va
dire l'appréhension du débat sur la
capitale par la loi sur le grand paris
sans savoir ce qui va se passer en 2012
ça présente pas un intérêt très
important qu'est ce que je vous ai dit
sa première adjointe anne hidalgo vous
lui tendez la main voulait dit parlons
nous
moi j'ai compris que dès que je
m'approchais ça lui crée beaucoup de
contrariété donc je veux brusquer
personne vous savez j'ai répondu je n'ai
répondu à aucune des attaques je
comprends la contrariété de certains je
comprends la peine de danièle hoffman
rispal qui par ailleurs a gagné sa
circonscription contraint sortants de
gauche il ya exactement dix ans dans des
conditions on va dire à peu similaire
mais inversés donc la retourne tout ce
que vous dites c'est pas la route on
sait que la vie politique a parfois des
situations plus complexes que l'évidence
que certains veulent bien montrer
allez on change de sujet anne lauvergeon
elle tacle le patron d'edf henri proglio
elle balance dans un livre qui sort ces
jours-ci ses conversations également
avec le président de la république c'est
ainsi que vous l'aimez atomic anne comme
on la surnomme moi je pense quelque
chose d'assez un peu rafraîchissant
effectivement dans une opération vérité
vue de sa fête mais au moins ça éclaire
un certain nombre de débats et surtout
c'est ce qu'elle dit d'ailleurs sur le
sur quel un sujet qui nous intéresse
beaucoup
qui est l'appel d'offres sur le grand
éolien où on voit que on a privilégié
edf et que 1 des projets notamment le
projet au large du havre qui était
totalement prêt l'appel d'offres a été
déclaré infructueux alors qu'il aurait
pu trouver preneur et que effectivement
au delà des stratégies industrielles et
de l'intérêt général
il ya beaucoup de petits intérêts qui
semaine c'est ce qu'a le démontre et qui
fait pas vraiment plaisir à ceux qui ont
envie justement de penser la politique
énergétique d'hier sans son intérêt
lilia sa stratégie elle elle visiblement
campagne elle à peu près sûr aujourd'hui
que la gauche va gagner la
présidentielle et elle espère en obtenir
quelque chose
un poste franchement je vous savez
beaucoup de choses que je sais faire
mais alors être dans les secrets de nos
vers lens a fait pas vraiment partie de
mes qualités mais a contrario on dit que
les jours dans les clous dorés proglio à
la tête d'edf son compte et ça ça vous
satisfait un peu de moi je vais vous
dire je joue de la même manière la
question c'est pas une question non
c'est une question de politique menée et
moi je souhaite que la politique qui
soit mené par par edf se fera une
politique qui engage à la diversité oui
qui engage qui qui est d'ailleurs une
politique mon profite du monopole quasi
du monopole français pour pouvoir
intervenir comme une entreprise privée
dans un certain nombre de pays essaie de
mettre la main sur un certain nombre de
réseaux électricité donc à une grande
ambiguïté dans le rôle d'edf en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya une
expertise bien savoir faire il ya un
sens du service public dans cette
entreprise qui sont extrêmement
importants et qui pourrait être
extrêmement utile s'il était mise à
profit de cette transition énergétique
et de ce que les écologistes souhaitent
c'est-à-dire la sortie du nucléaire sur
la centrale de penly la poursuite des
expertises après l'arrêt du réacteur
numéro 2 la semaine dernière
est ce que vous estimez qu'on ait
suffisamment informés en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que si on regarde
l'historique de cette journée c'est très
particulier
on a d'abord appris qu'un il y avait 1 1
le port de san non non non non tiens les
simplement une alarme g avait déclenché
l'arrêt du réacteur puis cette alarme
c'était issus de présence de fumée puis
la présence de fumée d'un départ de feu
puis en fait il y avait une fuite du
circuit primaire
les informations sont venues de manière
on va dire pas complète et pas immédiate
et on n'a toujours pas la réponse de
pourquoi au coeur d'un réacteur
il y à un incendie qui se déclenchent
d'où vient cette ville et comment elle
va revenir sur place dans quelques jours
oui mais ce qui est problématique avec
le nucléaire c'est que comme n'importe
quels seins d'une exploitation
industrielle il ya toujours un risque
sauf que le risque quand il est
nucléaire il est d'une proportion qui
n'a rien à voir avec aucune autre
activité industrielle
en termes d'ampleur et en termes
d'importance du danger d'ailleurs aucune
compagnie d'assurance n'accepte
d'assurer une centrale nucléaire
donc ce risque là si on peut faire
autrement que le prendre et c'est le cas
on voit dans d'autres pays
eh bien on doit pouvoir l'arrêter et
c'est pour ça qu'on défend la sortie du
nucléaire dans une interview au dauphiné
libéré ce matin le président candidat
est revenu sur son discours de grenoble
concédant qu'il éviterai aujourd'hui de
pointe et en particulier une communauté
est-ce que ce mea culpa de nicolas
sarkozy sur les roms vous satisfait vous
dit que c'est trop tard franchement je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure sur
l'environnement il est capable c'est sa
caractéristique principale de dire tout
et son contraire en l'espace de quelques
mois donc on ne sait plus tellement
alouettes
oui on se pose la question de savoir
quels sont ses réelles convictions pour
commencer et deuxièmement si tout n'est
que communication
effectivement c'est aussi ça qui conduit
à l'échec de sa politique c'est qu'il a
été à la fois un constant et puis
parfois très insultant c'était le cas du
discours de grenoble
dis tu rentres conseil d'administration
de nanterre 44 ans après y avoir mené la
contestation en mai 68 vous dites c'est
un beau pied de nez il ya des pirouettes
de l'histoire qui font sympathique je
crois que ça en fait partie
et pour finir j'avais envie de vous
demander vous vous ne vous estimiez pas
à ses prêtres ne pas avoir suffisamment
de carrière politique en deux carrure
politique pardon encore aujourd'hui pour
mener une campagne présidentielle pour
arquois avoir laissé alors eva joly qui
avait à peine 3 ans d'expérience
politique qui allait tout seul on n'est
pas candidat à l'élection présidentielle
à deux ou à trois mais il se trouve que
je fais partie je crois de ceux qui ont
fait campagne pour eva joly à ses côtés
avec elle même plus d'agents carrure
politique que vous pour y aller la
question c'est de savoir si les uns ou
les autres se sont prêtes elles elle se
sentait prête et d'ailleurs elle a
montré et de la ténacité et du caractère
bien sorti les sondages vous la voyez à
quel niveau
moi je ne souhaite pas un démenti je
souhaite simplement on va dire un
sursaut des électeurs et des électrices
que dirait finalement voté pour cette
femme
votez pour l'écologie c'est le bon vote
l'inde d'accord voulait pas venir à
chier parce que michèle rivasi par
exemple nous disait hier sur public
sénat la députée européenne qu'elle la
voyait à 5%
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
notre objectif a toujours été de faire
le meilleur score de l'écologie
politique donc évidemment ça au-dessus
de 5% et 8 5% il paraît que les comptes
de europe ecologie les verts sont dans
le rouge est ce que vous allez être en
faillite si elle ne dépasse pas 2% au
2ème et pourtant non j'ai déjà répondu à
une fois c'est faux la situation
financière est précaire et c'est pour ça
que c'est un appel à dons pour la
campagne électorale puisque
effectivement nous n'avons pas pu
contenir nos rangs c'est bien c'est eva
joly 2012 point fr vous pouvez faire
votre don jusqu'au jour 2 du projet
jusqu'au soir du premier tour
y compris par carte bancaire ce sera
avec plaisir a déjà reçu beaucoup de
dons parce qu'on vous a refusé un prêt
bancaire un jour à kout a fait récemment
pas d'ailleurs vraiment pour des raisons
à proprement parler financières et par
ailleurs nous avons anticipé cette
situation et quel que soit le résultat
de l'élection présidentielle je pense
que nous aurons les moyens de continuer
à je pense je suis certaine que nous
aurons les moyens de continuer à faire
vivre l'écologie politique et notre
mouvement merci à vos cécile duflot
merci père et une bon soir à tous on se
retourne en 15 minutes maintenant pour
le journal à 19h à tout de suite